alors des points
en foot mais bon poisson dit quoi trois
côtes cassées deux mois
d'indisponibilité
tu as de la chance qu'on gardait pas
porté plainte ouais c'est plutôt lui
donne ma chance je me suis retenu en
attendant tu es bon pour des tests
sanguins veulent être sûrs que tu es
plus sous psychotropes
ça fait six mois j'ai décroché c'est ce
qu'ils veulent vérifier
les messages effacés du portable ça
donne quoi à la télé sauf juge par sms
avec une liste de trois prénoms
en fait ces trois prénoms suivis d'une
lettre
en tout cas va falloir que je te trouve
un nouveau partenaire et ça va pas être
facile si pour une fois ils pouvaient
donc nous mais tu te plains tout le
temps ouais moi je me plais n'ya pas
accroché avec toi
mais moi tu me disais c'est différent
c'est toujours
tu devrais voir quelqu'un franck
quelqu'un qui tue puisse parler
quand j'étais avec toi je t'ai parlé
savard a changé non mais je pars d'un
professionnel je suis pas un monstre a
26 ans ok j'ai besoin de réponses
concrètes
tu te rends compte que tu les auras sans
doute jamais l'important c'est que je
puisse chercher ses mots je suis mort